wegen gerd joachim von fallois zu
schalten nach berlin denn wir erwarten
dort die fraktionsspitzen die genau zu
diesem thema wahrscheinlich auskunft
geben können gerd was wissen sie dazu
mehr
ja davon darf man ausgehen dass es
natürlich das top-thema auch heute hier
im politischen berlin schwere waffen
dann doch für die ukraine die
bundesregierung vor allen dingen der
bundeskanzler haben ja lange gebraucht
ist sie sich dazu offiziell durchringen
konnten nun sind 40
verteidigungsminister heute in ramstein
zusammengekommen und mit der
kommunikation
da hat es ja so ein bisschen in den
letzten tagen und wochen innerhalb der
ampel aber vor allen dingen auch in
bezüglich der öffentlichkeit das war
auch heute nicht anders denn die
verteidigungsministerin wir journalisten
bekamen bereits das rede formular vorab
sollte dann dort öffentlich verkünden
dass deutschland jetzt also auch gebhard
panzer liefern lassen wird in die
ukraine und diese rede von ihr fand
einfach nicht öffentlich statt die
kameras wurden ausgeschaltet niemand
bekam etwas mit man hat ja nur den
redetext weiter nicht sehr verwirrt
haben es dann mitbekommen hinter hat die
ministerin dann doch noch ein kurzes
statement abgehalten da hat sie das noch
mal klargestellt also die ampel hat
reagiert an nicht zuletzt natürlich auch
auf den druck der
oppositionsfraktion cdu csu die schon in
der vergangenen woche einen antrag
formuliert hatten und den diesem
donnerstag zur abstimmung stellen
wollten in dem sie schwere waffen für
die ukraine gefordert haben jetzt hat
die ampel reagiert zehn seiten hat der
ampel antrag davon war auszugehen dass
man nicht den unionsantrag übernehmen
wird wenngleich viele parlamentarier der
ampel fraktionen auch diesen antrag
hätten unterschreiben können aber das
geht natürlich demokratie technisch
nicht man kann den kanzler nicht im
regen stehen lassen und so hat man eben
einen eigenen antrag formuliert zehn
seiten ich habe es gesagt und ungefähr
jeder vierte satz in diesem antrag
lautet in gemeinsamer absprache mit
unseren partnern das ist wirklich schon
sehr auffällig in diesen zehn seiten und
da steht eben drin dass kraus maffei
diese panzer liefern darf und dass auch
ein weiteres schwere geschütze gedacht
wird unter anderem auch panzer zum
beispiel marder panzer darüber ist auch
schon länger diskutiert worden die
ebenfalls erst aufgearbeitet werden
müssen bei der deutschen industrie noch
stehen das sind natürlich alles sehr
alte kampf geräte wie bei der bundeswehr
bereits ausgemustert waren und
ringtausch das ist ein so ein begriff
der hier eine wichtige rolle spielt also
nato partner liefern sowjetisches
material und deutschland fühlt dann
dieses material für die nato-partner
wieder auf das ist der ringtausch und
rolf mützenich der fraktionschef der spd
hat jetzt das wort sondern nur am weg
plötzlich führt kurz ein und dann kommen
40 anfragen ja meine damen und herren
ganz herzlichen dank für common man
merkt die beschränkung von corona führen
auch mittlerweile dazu dass die etage
doch etwas voller wird und ich dennoch
ihnen alles an gesundheit wünschen
möchte auch für die nächsten wochen war
die pandemie ist nicht vorüber und
deswegen wünsche ihnen weiterhin alles
gute für die nächsten wochen wir stehen
vor wichtigen beratungen nicht nur jetzt
gleich hier in der
spd-bundestagsfraktion
sondern auch im deutschen bundestag wo
wir insbesondere gerade für uns
sozialdemokraten im sozialdemokraten
wichtig wir haben immer gesagt das was
wir plakatiert haben zur bundestagswahl
das halten wir auch ein versprechen die
mit uns nach hause gehen sollen das wird
gelöst und wir werden den mindestlohn
auf den weg bringen das ist für uns eine
ganz wichtige wichtiges versprechen dann
die menschen an die bürgerinnen und
bürger und das haben wir nicht nur
diejenigen etwas davon die mindestlohn
erhalten sondern auch die anderen die
wissen für gute arbeit wird auch gutes
geld bezahlt und damit kann man finde
ich auch etwas unbesorgt in einer
ohnehin beschwerten situationen
letztlich mit seinen familien und auch
mit seinen angehörigen letztens
versuchen
sich auf den weg zu machen auf der
anderen seite wissen sie dass natürlich
auch die debatte über den krieg in der
ukraine
der in den letzten sogenannten freien
sitzungswochen den letzten zwei
sitzungswochen über ostern an brutalität
nochmals zugenommen hat rücksichtsloser
noch geworden ist gegenüber der
zivilbevölkerung
und offensichtlich auch nicht zu einem
ende
findet dass das ein ganz wichtiges thema
ist umso mehr will ich hier begrüßen
auch für die spd-bundestagsfraktion dass
der generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen gut er ist in nach moskau reist
aber auch nach kiew und versucht genau
das zu tun was die vereinten nationen in
der charta der vereinten nationen zum
auftrag haben nämlich für den
internationalen frieden und die
sicherheit zu arbeiten und ich hoffe
dass er insbesondere auch von den
wichtigen mitgliedstaaten insbesondere
denen die permanenten mitglieder im
sicherheitsrat sind auch unterstützt
werden und wir wollen von seiten der
deutschen außenpolitik geben und damit
auch der gesamten bundesregierung in
alle unterstützung auch noch mal zu
sagen
bei diesem nicht einfachen weg und ich
hoffe wenigstens humanitäre ergebnisse
werden erzielt werden auf der anderen
seite haben wir in deutschland eine
debatte erlebt die sich doch sehr stark
in den letzten tagen allein auf die
frage der waffenlieferung konzentrierter
dazu hat die bundesregierung
offensichtlich weitere entscheidungen
getroffen die wir auch unterstützen und
auf der anderen seite und das ist auch
ziel und auch notwendigkeit eines
antrags den die drei
koalitionsfraktionen in dieser woche in
den deutschen bundestag einbringen dass
die politik gegenüber diesem krieg dass
er beendet werden soll eben auch mehr
bedeutet als waffenlieferungen es geht
um humanitäre hilfe es geht um
wirtschaftlichen wiederaufbau es geht um
die versorgung der flüchtlinge nicht nur
hier sondern auch der mehrzahl der
flüchtlinge die binnenflüchtlinge in der
ukraine sind und ich bin sehr froh dass
die drei koalitionsfraktionen hier zu
einem gemeinsamen antrag auch gefunden
die sich von dem ab was die union eben
auch eingebracht hat und ich freue mich
in dem zusammenhang natürlich auch auf
die debatte die wir im deutschen
bundestag zu dieser großen
herausforderungen haben so ich glaube
für die kürze der zeit reicht das
vielleicht erst mal ich sagen dass sie
die frage ein kollege zuerst dann
ihr parteigenosse michael roth schließt
eu-sanktionen gegen gerhard schröder
nicht mehr aus oder zumindest die
diskussionen darüber
wie absurd finden sie dass das jetzt
tatsächlich über sanktionen gegen den
spd altkanzler
gesprochen wird und ist das nicht in
allererster linie traurig
ich höre von ihnen jetzt die meldung
sollte es gehen so viele meldungen
tagtäglich manchmal auch an mir vorbei
wo sich sagen das ist bedauerlich für
einen
fraktionsvorsitzender das habe ich mir
persönlich aber auch anzulasten wir
haben und das müssen sie insbesondere
auch nochmal gegenüber den beiden
parteivorsitzenden fragen ein paar teil
auf dem sofa hannes eingeleitet worden
gegen gerd schröder dem sieht er aber
sie natürlich auch diejenigen die das
parteiordnungsverfahren angestrengt
haben mit interesse entgegen und wenn es
doch ergebnisse gibt werden sie davon
auch kenntnis erhalten
zwei fragen die eine frage noch mal zu
dem antrag gehen sie jetzt auf die union
zu damit möglicherweise noch ein
gemeinsamer antrag entsteht für die
abstimmung im bundestag und zweite frage
zu heute abend da was erwarten sie vom
koalitionsausschuss
[Musik]
natürlich gehen wir auf die union zu und
wir haben das auch schon gemacht die
union hat ja dankenswerterweise uns
ihren antrag auf arbeits ebene zur
verfügung gestellt wir haben das gleiche
getan es ist guter parlamentarischer
brauch dass man sich über initiativen
unterrichtet wir haben die union
eingeladen sich an unserem antrag zu
beteiligen wenn noch mal ein
ausführliches gespräch gewünscht wird
schließlich das auch nicht aus ob das
dann in verhandlungen überführt werden
kann das kann erst das gespräch ergeben
zum koalitionsausschuss
machte ich mir einen pünktlichen beginn
um 19 uhr und auch einen etwas
vorsichtigeres ende als der letzte
koalitionsausschuss also etwas früher
rinke weil sie mich das fragen uns zum
anderen erwarte ich mir eine ernsthafte
und belastbare diskussion
ich glaube dass für uns ist jetzt erst
mal wichtig ist uns über die aktuelle
situation nochmal zu informieren dass
zwischen den partei fraktion und
regierungsspitzen es einen
informationsaustausch gibt sowohl das
was das parlament in dieser
sitzungswoche macht aber eben auch was
die regierung jetzt vielleicht in den
letzten stunden auch noch mal konkret
entschieden als der finanzminister kommt
aus den usa ich glaube das ist auch
nicht ganz unwichtig hier auch nochmal
bescheid zu wissen was entweder auf den
öffentlichen veranstaltungen oder auch
im
vertraulichen gespräch das eine oder
andere erörtert worden ist also von
daher erwarte ich mir einen
koalitionsausschuss der dem
informationsaustausch und der klärung
auch dient er ist mal
mützenich ich würde gerne noch mal
nachfragen zu ihrem auftritt heute
morgen im ard morgenmagazin die spd sagt
er seit tagen oder warnt vor der
lieferung auch von panzern aus deutscher
produktion da steht auch nicht explizit
anders als bei der union im spd oder im
ampel antrag drin waren sie heute morgen
informiert dass es zu dieser
entscheidung der bundesregierung kommt
dass jetzt auch bis zu 50 g panzer
geliefert werden sollen an die ukraine
weil das ja doch noch mal eine zäsur ist
weil es weitergeht als alles was bisher
stattgefunden hat nun das liegt in ihrem
ermessen ob das was heute entschieden
oder möglicherweise heute entschieden
worden ist sozusagen eine neue qualität
hat ich finde dass deutschland zusammen
mit den internationalen partnern
bereits eine sehr große zahl von ganz
unterschiedlichen militärischen gerät
auch der ukraine überlassen hat entweder
aus bundeswehrbeständen aber jetzt auch
große finanzen noch mal bereitet dass
die ukraine auf dem internationalen
markt die güte auch einkaufen kann die
sie glaubt notwendigerweise in ihre in
ihrer situation auch besitzen zu wollen
und auf der anderen seite ist es so dass
ich finde dass eben auch diese
entscheidung der bundesregierung
zusammen mit den partnern die getroffen
worden sind verantwortbar sind sind
schon gepanzerte fahrzeuge in der
vergangenheit geliefert worden und es
werden auch noch wahrscheinlich in
zukunft weitere gepanzerte fahrzeuge
geliefert werden heute morgen informiert
darüber sie wissen dass entscheidungen
die die bundesregierung im
bundessicherheitsrat
trifft so getroffen werden wie es nach
gesetz nach dem gesetz erfolgt und
daraus können sie auch ihre
schlussfolgerung ziehen
herr szymanski
wenn jetzt der weg frei ist für gepard
lieferung heißt dass es in einem
nächsten schritt auch die mader
geliefert werden dürften
nochmal ich glaube dass genau diese
fragen berechtigterweise sowohl das was
im grundgesetz aber auch zwischen der
exekutiven arbeit und legislativen
arbeit in deutschland klar geregelt ist
exekutive entscheidungen sind sie sind
nicht nur geheimnis bewährt was er ist
ja eben auch schon mal angesprochen hat
sondern sie müssen auch von konkreten
informationen getragen sein und die die
eben auch entscheidungen treffen müssen
ja auch diese entscheidung verantworten
da braucht man keine großen belehrungen
von anderen sondern ich glaube da gibt
es ein abwägungsprozess und deswegen
sage ich noch mal sind in der
vergangenheit gepanzerte fahrzeuge
geliefert worden es werden jetzt
gepanzerte fahrzeuge geliefert und
möglicherweise auch in zukunft und mir
ist das sage ich glaube ich für die
gesamte spd bundestagsfraktion immer
wichtig dass wir auf der einen seite mit
internationalen partnern in dieser frage
gemeinsam handeln dass wir auf der
anderen seite nicht verkennen heute ist
der generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen in moskau wir haben
diplomatische
wichtige entscheidung auch in der
nächsten zeit zu treffen nehmen sie die
konferenzen g7 format g20 format und
viele andere dinge auch das können wir
nur mit partnern letztlich erreichen und
ich finde die menschen die in der
ukraine unter diesen brutalen krieg
leben müssen auch darauf hoffen dass wir
mit dazu in der lage sind diesen krieg
jetzt so schnell wie möglich auch zu
beenden und das wird man insbesondere
glaube ich auch durch den einsatz auf
der einen seite das humanitäre hilfe
geleistet wird wirtschaftliche
wiederaufbau diplomatie und viele andere
dinge auch erreichen können
becker
auch noch mal dazu ich würde einfach
gerne mal persönlich fragen also sie
sind ja jemand der da so zu sagen sie ja
auch auf andere lösungen setzt haben
heute morgen auch noch mal gesagt man
müsste eigentlich auch den fokus weg von
militärischen lenken was bedeutet es für
sie persönlich wie empfinden sie da das
jetzt eben die gebäude auf den weg
geschickt werden sollen und sie haben ja
selber gesagt können dann auch mehr sein
wie schätzen sie das auch persönlich ein
was bedeutet das für sie also eine ganz
konkrete entscheidung betrifft sozusagen
nicht meine
persönliche
letztlich einschätzung zu dieser
situation ich finde diesen krieg
verheerender sein aggressions krieg er
ist ein völker rechtsbruch putin hat
ihnen zusammen mit einer clique auch
entschieden hat auch bundeskanzler den
bundeskanzler belogen hat dem britischen
premierminister belogen den
französischen staatspräsidenten das geht
auch an uns allen nicht spurlos vorüber
auch nicht an mir aber auf der anderen
seite ist auch nach meinem dafürhalten
die erfahrung zumindestens auch der
vergangenheit so dass wir am ende
verschiedene
instrumente und schritte brauchen um
einen krieg zu einem ende zu führen
wichtig wäre doch zb eine humanitäre
feuerpause humanitäre korridore dafür
setzt sich generalsekretär gut er ist in
diesen tagen ein ich hoffe dass es
weiterhin und selbst wenn es dann nicht
öffentliche kontakte zwischen der
ukrainischen und russischen regierung
gibt über gefangenenaustausch etc alles
das sind kleine aber nicht ganz
unwichtige schritte wo wir dann hoffen
dass der krieg auch mit diesen maßnahmen
zu einem ende geführt wird ansonsten
glaube ich machen sie sich über mich
wahrscheinlich zu unrecht sorgen
kollege
sondern eine frage zum sondervermögen
müssen sich erfordert die unionsfraktion
jetzt neben diesem tilgungs und und
wirtschaftsplan auch noch ein beratungs
und aufsichtsgremium
inwieweit können sie denn also die ampel
der dieser forderungen nach seinem
gremium entgegen kommen und dadurch
letztlich die notwendigen stimmen für
die geplante grundgesetzänderung
zusammen zu bekommen das ist jetzt
einbringen können wir werden uns dann
natürlich in den nächsten wochen noch
mal gemeinsam auf parlamentarischer
ebene aber auch mit der regierung
abstimmen
wie kommen dass es am ende zu eben einer
notwendigen zweidrittelmehrheit und
welche notwendigen vielleicht
präzisierungen sind dann auch noch
erforderlich dass die union hier
mitreden will ist ja ganz klar weil sie
wird ja auch sich hoffentlich und ich
denke auch die gesamte fraktion der
union nicht der abstimmung verweigern
von daher hat es glaube ich der
fraktionsvorsitzende nachts auch noch
eine große aufgabe vor sich eine
opposition im deutschen bundestag und
die opposition ist er größer als die der
cdu/csu aufzustellen dass sie eben auch
letztlich der staat verantwortung
gerecht wird die auch eine opposition
erfüllen muss in deutschland
rolf mützenich der fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd das sondervermögen die 100
milliarden der bundeswehr wird hier
morgen in erster lesung stattfinden und
es ging natürlich den großteil dieser
pressekonferenz um die frage schwere
waffen in die ukraine gerade rolf
mützenich er war ja lange jahre
außenpolitiker er gehört zum linken
flügel der spd und gerade dieser linke
flügel macht es dem bundeskanzler ja
nicht leicht und in dem gemeinsamen
ampel antrag der jetzt mittlerweile
vorliegt und am donnerstag abgestimmt
werden soll die frage ist ob die cdu
ihren antrag dann zurückzieht die
cdu/csu ja und in diesem gemeinsamen
antrag der ampel da steht nämlich darin
dass schwere waffen nur geliefert werden
sollen im sogenannten ring
tauschverfahren heute morgen dann hat
die bundesverteidigungsministerium
mitgeteilt dass gebhard panzer also
schwere waffen von kraussmaffei quasi in
die ukraine geliefert werden dürfen da
war nichts mehr von ringtausch mit einem
nato partner die rede also man sieht
kommunikativ da gibt es noch einiges zu
tun britta haßelmann ist die
fraktionsvorsitz der grünen auch sie hat
sich vor ihrer fraktionssitzung heute
geäußert
wir verurteilen den angriffskrieg von
putin auf die ukraine die brutalität und
die grausamkeit dieses krieges
schockiert uns und trifft uns alle bis
ins mark die nachrichten über
kriegsverbrechen
gräueltaten und das ausmaß dieses krieg
ist leid und die zerstörung auch auf die
zivilbevölkerung sind dramatisch deshalb
versichern wir auch in dieser woche im
parlament der ukraine noch einmal unsere
unterstützung klar ist neben der
humanitären hilfe der wirtschaftlichen
unterstützung und auch den
waffenlieferungen die wir nach dem
selbstverteidigungsrecht der ukraine
bisher leisten gemeinsam und abgestimmt
mit unseren europäischen partnern in der
internationalen staatengemeinschaft und
mit g7 vereinbart werden wir sowohl die
frage der anforderung was militärisches
material angeht im hinblick auf den
ringtausch
als auch auf schwere waffen
nachkommen wir werden in einer
parlamentarischen antrags initiative als
ampel auch nochmal
bekräftigen dass wir diese
vollumfängliche unterstützung an die
ukraine leisten das ist wichtig und
notwendig und uns als bündnis 90/die
grüne aber auch in der ampel gemeinsam
ein ziel dieses in dieser sitzungswoche
zum ausdruck zu bringen
wir werden diese antrags initiative auch
der union anbieten sie diese zu
unterstützen denn in dieser kritischen
situation
in der in europa ein freies land
angegriffen wird durch diesen aggressor
putin und seiner russischen armee geht
es auch darum gemeinsam zu agieren die
sicherheits und friedensordnung in
unserem europäischen
gemeinsamen verständnis ist massiv
gefährdet und deshalb erwarten wir auch
von der union dass es an dieser stelle
die bereitschaft gibt
gemeinsam zu agieren und keine
parteipolitischen oder taktischen
spiele und auseinandersetzung zu pflegen
das gilt auch im hinblick auf die
anstehenden debatten die wir in dieser
woche beginnen zum sondervermögen
alle wissen dass die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr die in den sechzehn letzten
jahren verteidigungsminister der union
zu verantworten haben miserabel ist und
dass wir dringend im
kontext eines sondervermögens dafür
sorge tragen müssen dass die
verteidigungs und bündnisfähigkeit
unseres bundes verbessert werden muss
hierzu gibt es einen vorschlag und ich
erwarte dass die union diesen vorschlag
auch konstruktiv begleitet und nicht für
parteitaktik nutzt denn es geht um die
sicherheits- und friedensordnung in
unserem land das sind fragen die werden
uns in dieser woche intensiv
beschäftigen
ja diese erwartungshaltung von britta
haßelmann teilen viel und wir werden ja
sicherlich gleich friedrich merz dazu
hören aber zunächst wo wir über schalten
da steht jetzt die afd profil glaube ich
hat gerade das wort was bedeutet dass
das sehen wir jetzt wir haben eine
vermögenspreise inflation in den vor
allen dingen in den immobilienmärkte das
merken die mieter das merken auch käufer
menschen aus dem mittelstand und aus
normalen einkommensschichten können sich
ein eigenheim nicht mehr leisten und
wenn sie es vorher gekauft haben wird
ihnen jetzt durch die zinswende laufen
sie gefahr dass ihnen die hypotheken um
die ohren fliegen also wir werden hier
in eine gravierende finanzkrise hinein
kommen wir haben davor gewarnt und dazu
kommt ja auch noch diese sehr ungünstige
entwicklung speziell in unserem land wir
haben uns abhängig gemacht von der
energieversorgung aus dem ausland wir
sind aus der kernenergie ausgestiegen
parallel dazu aus der kohleverstromung
kein industriestaat kommt auf diese
wahnwitzige idee so etwas zu vollziehen
wir haben das auch als afd immer
kritisiert was wir brauchen in unserem
land ist energiesicherheit zu
bezahlbaren preisen
denn diese diese inflation nun in den
angebotspreisen für energie
schlägt ja nicht nur bei den
privathaushalten durch sondern eben auch
bei mittleren kleinen betrieben die am
rande des ruins sind weil sie das alles
nicht mehr bezahlen können wir haben vor
dieser entwicklung gewarnt und die
konsequenzen sehen wir jetzt wir haben
jetzt eine eine vorjahres inflation
glaubt die zahl wurde sogar von der
bundesregierung rausgegeben von 6,1
prozent die erzeugerpreise sind schon
länger über 30 prozent das muss man sich
mal vorstellen
die ezb und die bundesbank sind
ursprünglich von inflationszielen von 2
prozent ausgegangen also einfach nur mal
so als benchmark wo wir uns hier gerade
bewegen und ich kann ihnen versprechen
es wird nicht bei 6 prozent bleiben die
ganz große inflation wird kommen die
natürlich auch in absehbarer zeit mittel
bis langfristig ich gebe dem euro noch
fünf bis zehn jahre dann wird er crashen
und dann werden wir nachher überhaupt
gar nichts mehr haben aufgrund dieser
eklatanten vermögens umverteilung und
einer währung die diese entwicklung gar
nicht aushalten kann denn in der
ökonomie ist es dann so dass es mein
schlusssatz ist es niemals so wie man es
sich wünscht dass es so kommen soll
sondern es kommt immer so wie es kommen
muss weil man das voraussehen kann
volkswirte haben das gesagt haben dass
auch vorausgesehen es wurde alles
geflissentlich ignoriert und vielleicht
sollte man auch mal darüber nachdenken
in zukunft sich eine kompetente
bundesregierung zusammen zu wählen die
auch von dem stück entscheidung für die
bevölkerung trifft kino vielen dank
zum thema kompetenz der bundesregierung
habe ich auch deine zum thema ukraine
waffenlieferung hier nehmen wir mit
großer besorgnis den kurs und sehen auch
ein großer besorgnis den kurs der
bundesregierung aber auch natürlich auch
der union im krieg hier in der ukraine
denn mit dem heutigen tag sind alle
dämme gebrochen
bundeskanzler schweiz gegenüber den
hardlinern aus fdp grünen union und auch
seiner eigenen spd eingeknickt neben der
koalition mittlerweile die
cdu/csu-fraktion die ja auch diese woche
im bundestag ein antrag einbringt um die
lieferung schwerer waffen in die ukraine
vorzusehen statt auf vernunft zu setzen
begibt sich hier die ampel regierung auf
kriegskurs und will die lieferung von
panzern aus beständen der industrie an
die ukraine ermöglichen die
bundesregierung und die unions parteien
betreiben hier wirklich ein absolut
verantwortungsloses spiel mit dem feuer
denn sie wissen dass aussicht putins
bereits die präsident losen
wirtschaftssanktionen einer
kriegserklärung gleich kam die auf die
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag lehnt
deutsche waffenlieferungen krisen und
kriegsgebiete grundsätzlich weiterhin ab
sie tragen zur eskalation bei liegen
nicht im deutschen interesse
und deutschlandweit hier auch gefahr
immer tiefer in den
russisch-ukrainischen krieg verwickelt
zu werden wir müssen alles soweit also
kino copala den wir etwas unsanft
unterbrechen müssen denn jetzt kommt
friedrich merz die cdu/csu hat diese
waffenlieferung gefordert die sofortige
hilfe für die ukraine die ampel hat sich
schwergetan hat jetzt einen eigenen
antrag eingebracht den eigentlich die
union mit unterstützen könnte mal sehen
was der fraktionschef der cdu/csu dazu
zu sagen hat ich gebe webber mit
äußerstem befremden zur kenntnis
genommen dass der bundeskanzler
beabsichtigt bereits morgen nachmittag
zu einer auslandsreise aufzubrechen wir
halten das für unpassend wir haben
wichtige themen im deutschen bundestag
zu besprechen wir haben einen sehr
schwierigen sachverhalt zu bewerten und
zu beurteilen im hinblick auf
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das
alles ist nicht akzeptabel wir nehmen es
zur kenntnis wir werden trotzdem die
debatte im deutschen bundestag führen es
gibt morgen nachmittag eine erste
aussprache in der ersten lesung zum
vorschlag der bundesregierung die
bundeswehr besser auszustatten mit einem
entsprechenden antrag
das grundgesetz zu ändern und auch ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr zu
errichten sowie das bis jetzt vorliegt
ist es aus unserer sicht nicht
zustimmungsfähig wir sind allerdings
unverändert der meinung dass es sich
lohnt mit der koalition über dieses
thema zu reden es hat leider in den
letzten acht wochen nur einen
gesprächstermin bisher gegeben wir
hoffen dass heute nachmittag in einem
zweiten gesprächstermin weitere
ergebnisse erzielt werden können aber
wir sind von einer einigung noch sehr
weit entfernt wir haben in dieser woche
am donnerstag eine debatte im deutschen
bundestag über einen antrag den wir
gestellt haben zum thema
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine wir
haben diesen antrag gestellt weil wir
eine wochenlange diskussion in der
koalition mit einer beschlussfassung des
deutschen bundestages hoffen zu beenden
ich begrüße ausdrücklich dass die
koalitionsfraktionen jetzt auf dem weg
hin sind zu einem eigenen antrag ich
erneuere unser angebot diesem antrag
auch beizutreten und ihm zuzustimmen das
setzt allerdings voraus dass wir noch an
der einen oder anderen stelle diesen
antrag auch gemeinsam besprechen und
auch ändern aber wir befinden uns hier
auf einem gemeinsamen weg der auch in
der tat am donnerstag zu einem
gemeinsamen ergebnis führen könnte
wichtig ist dass wir hier eine klare
haltung einnehmen ich will das hier
ausdrücklich sagen wir tun uns alle
schwer mit der entscheidung in die
ukraine schwere waffen zu liefern das
ist nichts was uns leicht fällt zu
entscheiden wir haben das sorgfältig
abgewogen wir haben darüber lange
diskutiert es gibt auch aus unserer
fraktion sehr besorgte stimmen die ihr
vor einer eskalation in diesem konflikt
warnen wir sind aber nach langer
diskussion gemeinsam und ganz
übereinstimmend zu dem ergebnis gekommen
dass es richtig ist jetzt auch weitere
waffen in die ukraine zu liefern und
zwar so wie die bündnispartner innerhalb
der nato und die mitgliedstaaten
innerhalb der europäischen union sich
das gemeinsam vorgenommen haben hier
sollte deutschland nicht der bremser
bleiben wir wollen auch nicht dass
deutschland allein voran geht sondern
wir wollen dass deutschland das tut was
andere in der europäischen union und
auch andere in der nato für richtig
halten sie nur in diesem zusammenhang
war immer darauf hinweisen dass die
vereinigten staaten von amerika heute
schon mehr tun als alle europäischen
staaten zusammen da kann man nicht davon
sprechen dass nun von deutschland aus
die gefahr eines dritten weltkrieges
ausgeht diese bemerkung des
bundeskanzlers halten wir für absolut
falsche unpassend wenn sie richtig wäre
dann wären andere schon viel weiter auf
dem weg zum dritten weltkrieg als
deutschland das ist eine bemerkung die
in diesem zusammenhang einfach unpassend
ist wir wollen diesen krieg so schnell
wie möglich beenden und ich wiederhole
das was ich an anderer stelle auch hier
schon einmal gesagt habe wir müssen
putin jetzt stoppen und dafür muss die
ukraine in die lage versetzt werden dies
auch mit militärischen mitteln zu tun
wir werden die diskussion heute
nachmittag in unserer fraktion relativ
kurz machen können weil der text bei uns
übereinstimmen so beschlossen worden ist
schon in den gremien der fraktion und
ich hoffe dass heute nachmittag in einer
wahrscheinlich länger dauernden
diskussion in der spd bundestagsfraktion
ein ergebnis erzielt wird auf deren
grundlage wir dann gemeinsam noch einmal
beraten können ob es am donnerstag dann
eine gemeinsame beschlussfassung im
deutschen bundestag gibt ich hoffe dass
ich hoffe dass damit auch die
streitereien in der koalition beendet
sind der bundeskanzler bekäme mit einer
solchen gemeinsamen beschlussfassung des
deutschen bundestages eine breite
parlamentarische mehrheit für das was
deutschland dann tun könnte und tun
müsste aber an der stelle sind wir noch
nicht wir hoffen dass wir bis
donnerstagmorgen zu diesem punkte kommen
herzlichen dank
ja sehr geehrte damen und herren die
rede des bundeskanzlers über die
zeitenwende war am sonntag acht wochen
alt und in dieser zeit hat die ampel
eine beachtliche lernkurve hingelegt von
einer ursprungs positionierung es gebe
in deutschland gar nichts was man an
waffen liefern könnte zum bekenntnis
jetzt schwere waffen in die ukraine zur
stärkung der verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu liefern dazu hat es die union
gebraucht damit der streit in der
koalition beendet werden konnte wenn er
denn beendet ist wir werden das nach den
fraktionssitzungen
der koalitionsfraktionen
sehen aber das war unsere initiative die
notwendig war mit einem klaren hinweis
darauf dass es im deutschen bundestag
eine mehrheit der mitte des bundestages
gibt dafür stärker die choreo ukraine zu
unterstützen und unser arm und unser
hand bleibt ausgestreckt gegenüber den
ampelkoalition ehren für einen
gemeinsamen antrag um eine breite
parlamentarische mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag zu ermöglichen wir sind sehr
gespannt ob die koalition die kraft dazu
hat mit uns gemeinsam so einen antrag zu
beschließen der zweite punkt bei den 100
milliarden wir haben zu einer ersten
lesung dieser woche im deutschen
bundestag zugestimmt obwohl es noch
keine gemeinsamen ergebnisse zu dieser
thematik gibt dabei ist es richtig dass
wir hier auch einen straffen zeitplan
einhalten also diese woche die erste
lesung im bundestag und weitere
gespräche darüber wie diese 100
milliarden im grundgesetz verankert
werden können wir haben größtes
interesse dass es hier gelingt ein
ergebnis zu erzielen
auf basis des jetzigen textes ist das
nicht möglich für uns entscheidend dass
diese 100 milliarden ausschließlich für
die bundeswehr ausschließlich für die
verteidigung zur verfügung stehen das
ist aktuell noch nicht gesichert aber in
dem sinne verhandeln wir weiter frau
schweizer
den antrag so drauf schaut dann ist doch
all das bevorzugte mittel nach wie vor
der ringtausch
sie hatten sich für schnelle und direkte
waffenlieferung ausgesprochen ist das
für sie verhandeln
wir haben uns den text genau angeschaut
der ist wie üblich zu lang aber an den
entscheidenden stellen noch nicht
präzise genug und das ist eine von
mehreren stellen hier steht die
formulierung etwa mit ringtausch drin
das ist eine option aber wir wollen dass
es auch direkte lieferungen gibt und
dass es hier nicht nur im wegen dieses
ringtausch auslieferung gibt da scheint
die koalition schon weiter zu sein als
dieser text denn so wie wir den
agenturmeldungen nachricht meldungen
heute entnehmen konnten sollte ja sogar
der gepard panzer geliefert werden
übrigens das komplizierteste
waffensystem dass es in der bundeswehr
für solche zwecke überhaupt gibt also
offensichtlich ist die koalition da auch
schon einen schritt weiter
wir erkennen das ja im text den die
koalition vorgelegt hat auch die
befähigung für das bedienen der
waffensysteme für die ukrainische armee
die soldatinnen soldaten
vorgesehen ist und zwar dies auch auf
westeuropäischem gebiet von daher gehen
wir davon aus dass es sich hier einfach
um unklarheiten im anderen teil des
textes was die waffenlieferung anbelangt
geht und gehen davon aus dass die ampel
in der lage ist hier mit uns über eine
klarheit des textes zu verhandeln meine
und unsere interpretation ist die dass
es sich hier um verschiedene elemente
handelt ringtausch ja aber auch direkte
waffenlieferungen ganz offensichtlich
die möglich sein müssen ok vielen dank
vielen dank
ja meine damen und herren so weit also
die position der union und sie haben es
gehört bei der frage schwerer waffen da
hat die cdu csu in der vergangenen woche
einen eigenen antrag vorgelegt friedrich
merz hat ist klar gesagt man hat den
antrag der ampel der jetzt vorgelegt
wurde durchgelesen und an und für sich
kann man dem zustimmen möchte an der
einen oder anderen stelle ein paar
präzisierungen vornehmen da kann man nur
hoffen dass das die gegenseite hört und
man dann gemeinsam am donnerstag in
dieser woche diesen antrag verabschieden
wird hier im deutschen bundestag
friedrich merz hat sein statement mit
einer massiven kritik an bundeskanzler
begonnen denn in der tat ist es ein
wenig verwunderlich da hat der
oppositionschef nicht ganz unrecht dass
der bundeskanzler am mittwochabend zu
einer japan reise aufbricht in einer
sitzungswoche in der es hier wirklich um
tod und leben geht um wichtige
grundsatzentscheidungen am donnerstag am
freitag zum beispiel geht es auch noch
mal um die bundesführung den wehrbericht
wehrbeauftragten also in der tat
merkwürdig dass der bundeskanzler dabei
nicht anwesend sein wird es gibt zwei
diskussions felder einmal eben diese
frage schwerer waffen in die ukraine und
das andere das wurde hier auch natürlich
breit behandelt ist das sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr 100 milliarden euro
cdu csu und spd fdp und grüne wollen das
gerne im grundgesetz verankert wissen
dafür braucht man eine
zweidrittelmehrheit das bedeutet
natürlich von seiten der ampel man muss
gucken dass man die union mit nimmt und
da hat friedrich merz gesagt da ist noch
zu wenig passiert wir sind überhaupt in
den vergangenen wochen erst einmal
angesprochen worden zu einem gemeinsamen
gespräch das ist in der tat wenig da
gibt es die erste lesung jetzt am
mittwoch und alexander dobrindt hat
gesagt man hat sich darauf eingelassen
und hofft dass innerhalb des
parlamentarischen verfahrens die ampel
dann noch auf die bedenken der union
eingehen werden also erste lesung am
mittwoch und dann muss weiter in diesem
punkt sondervermögen bundeswehr 100
milliarden heftig diskutiert werden und
die fdp fraktion ist mittlerweile auch
schon zusammen getreten christian doerr
ihr fraktionsvorsitzender hat natürlich
vor der fraktionssitzung auch etwas
gesagt zu der entwicklung richtung
schwere waffen die jetzt auch in die
ukraine geliefert werden sollen
der brutale angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine von seiten russlands geht jetzt
in den dritten monat meine damen und
herren und uns erreichen jeden tag
schreckliche nachrichten von getöteten
zivilisten von zerstörten städten und 1
will ich ganz klar sagen daran dürfen
wir uns nicht gewöhnen und deswegen
müssen wir alles in unserer macht
stehende tun um die ukraine in ihrem
kampf in ihrem krieg gegen russland zu
unterstützen der bundesparteitag der
freien demokraten hat am wochenende
sicher sehr klar positioniert
insbesondere bei der frage der
waffenlieferung wir sind dafür dass auch
schwere waffen in die ukraine geliefert
werden können diese haltung ist auch die
haltung der fdp fraktion im deutschen
bundestag
und dass die ukraine sich verteidigen
kann ich darüber dass muss man immer
wieder betonen dass die ukraine sich
verteidigen kann ist auch im
sicherheitspolitischen interessen der
bundesrepublik deutschland deswegen bin
ich froh dass wir uns gemeinsam mit
unseren koalitionspartnern
sozialdemokraten und grünen auf einen
gemeinsamen antrag für diese
sitzungswoche verständigt haben der
genau die position der freien demokraten
widerspiegelt nämlich dass wir als
deutschland bereit sind eben auch wie
foren erwähnt schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern das ist ein ganz
wichtiges politisches signal das gilt
einerseits für den bereits angelaufenen
sogenannten ringtausch das heißt die
lieferung ausgestellten osteuropäischer
nato partner direkt in die ukraine und
gleichzeitige ersetzung durch deutsche
rüstungsgüter an diese partner aber eben
auch direkte lieferungen an die ukraine
und deswegen begrüßen wir dass die
bundesregierung bereits den export des
gepanzert genehmigt hat die
bundesverteidigungsministerium hat heute
in ramstein ja genau dazu stellung
genommen
es war ja bereits ende vergangener woche
angekündigt dass auch die kolleginnen
kollegen der unionsfraktion einen
eigenen antrag in den deutschen
bundestag einbringen der hat uns am
sonntagabend erreicht und wir müssen
feststellen dass sehen wir jetzt ja auch
in der bewertung durch viele
militärexperten dass dieser antrag
etliche ungenauigkeiten hat und aus
unserer sicht auch unvollständig ist
deswegen war uns als regierungsfraktion
wichtig hier einen vollumfänglichen
antrag der sich mit allen aspekten
beschäftigt schwerpunktmäßig mit der
frage der waffenlieferung aber mit allen
aspekten beschäftigt es ist ja gute
tradition gerade in so schwierig
schwierigen geopolitischen zeiten dass
die demokratischen kräfte die
demokratische mitte des deutschen
bundestages hier zusammensteht
insbesondere bei militärischen
grundsatzfragen und auch gemeinsam
entscheidet und daher laden wir die
union sehr herzlich ein dem antrag der
regierungsfraktionen beizutreten ich
glaube das wäre ein starkes signal und
würde auch dazu führen dass die union
jetzt in dieser frage verantwortung
übernimmt ich habe gerade betont dass
die fdp die lieferung von schweren
waffen unterstützt es gibt die
befürchtungen dass solche lieferungen
zur zielscheibe für russland werden
könnten teilen sie diese sorge ja wir
haben ja ich bin noch mal auf das was
die union die letzten tage gemacht hat
in dem zusammenhang eingehen ich hielte
es für falsch dass der deutsche
bundestag im einzelnen über
waffensysteme spricht im einzelnen über
ganz konkrete lieferrouten
möglicherweise das ist regierungshandeln
sie haben vollkommen recht das ist eine
sicherheitspolitische situation und das
kann man nicht sozusagen in der
öffentlichkeit besprechen das würde
gerade zu dem aggressor wladimir putin
in die hände spielen insofern ist das
eine frage die immer mit bedacht werden
muss und deswegen rate ich auch an der
stelle zur verbalen abrüstung und zur
politischen sachfrage zurückzukehren das
politische statement in dieser woche des
deutschen bundestages als
volksvertretung wird eindeutig sein das
ist ja auch der große wille der menschen
in deutschland und das teilen wir und
deswegen sollten wir uns auf das was
dann ich sag mal militär technisch
abläuft nicht in der öffentlichkeit
konzentrieren das wäre geradezu
fahrlässig
christian dior der fraktionschef der fdp
hat sich noch mal gesagt indem
unionsantrag über schwere waffen da sein
so einige ungenauigkeiten
deswegen habe die ampel einen eigenen
antrag vorgelegt hat das ist natürlich
auch sehr geschönt vom
fdp-fraktionsvorsitzende es war dringend
notwendig dass sie drei ampel fraktionen
sich einigen auf einen gemeinsamen
antrag und friedrich merz ja angeboten
wenn man mal ganz kurz darüber reden
könnte zwei drei sachen ausräumen könnte
wäre die cdu csu ja mit an bord
jedenfalls ist es so dass man heute erst
zu einer gemeinsamen linie gefunden hat
die allerdings jetzt in den fraktionen
diskutiert wird geht panzer sollen
geliefert werden von der deutschen
industrie direkt in die ukraine das ist
ein fortschritt schwere waffen nicht nur
über den ringtausch sondern auch direkt
zu liefern das hat ja auch gerade der
fdp-fraktionschef gesagt und mit der
einigkeit da war es ja so eine sache
frau strack-zimmermann sie ist nicht
etwa in der opposition ein sie gehört
zur regierung tragenden fdp die
ausschussvorsitzenden
verteidigungsausschuss hatte in der
vergangenen woche den bundeskanzler
eingeladen morgen früh im
verteidigungsausschuss zu den aktuellen
fragen stellung zu nehmen
das wurde allgemein brüskiert
aufgenommen vor allen dingen von seiten
der spd und der kanzler hat jetzt
mitteilen lassen dass er gerne kommt
aber erst am 11 bis dahin dürften sich
die wogen wohl wir gerettet haben ja
ganz andere wogen hat die die links die
linksfraktion mit ihrer partei hier sie
hat ihre parteivorsitzende verloren
bekanntermaßen es wird im juni ein
parteitag geben da soll der gesamte
vorstand neu gewählt werden die linke
sitzt ja überhaupt nur hier im deutschen
bundestag mit 4,9 prozent hat sich die
fünf prozent hürde nicht geschafft dafür
drei direktmandate geholt deswegen ist
sie dann doch hier in den deutschen
bundestag eingezogen sei es drum dietmar
bartsch den ko fraktionsvorsitzende der
linken hat auch sich heute erklärt vor
der fraktionssitzung und die linker
natürlich traditionell eine ganz andere
auffassung sie ist der meinung alles
militärische wird zu keiner lösung des
konflikts
keiner lösung des konflikts führen
dietmar bartsch der fraktionsvorsitzende
es kann nur eins geben eine forderung
die unverändert ist dass dieser krieg so
schnell es geht gestoppt werden muss und
dass man alles unternehmen muss dass
dieser krieg gestoppt in diesem sinne
habe ich auch eine gewisse hoffnung dass
harris heute in moskau es und danach
nach kiew reist vielleicht ist es ja
möglich daß der un-generalsekretär hier
etwas bewegung oder stop befördern kann
sicherlich nicht schlecht wenn das
geschehen würde in jedem fall ist die
mission von herrn sieht er seine chance
für frieden und im übrigen auch für
rückgewinnung der glaubwürdigkeit der
vereinten nationen dass die deutsche
debatte betrifft will ich auch
ausdrücklich festhalten dass die der
furchtbaren situation in der ukraine
nicht gerecht wird es wird vor allen
dingen über waffenlieferungen weniger
über diplomatie auch ganz wenig über die
frage von
rohstofflieferungen also nicht nur gas
erdöl sondern auch andere
rohstofflieferungen geredet und ich
glaube dass im moment wir als deutscher
bundestag ein gehöriges maß an
selbstbeschäftigung der öffentlichkeit
vermitteln am ende des tages muss man
festhalten dass die debatten wie sie
hier aktuell innerhalb der ampel aber
auch zwischen ampeln und union geführt
werden das geschäft was wladimir putin
will nämlich die spaltung des westens
ein stückweit bedienen und ich sage ganz
klar wir haben ein absolutes
kommunikations desaster ein desolat des
kommunikationsverhalten wenn ich mir
anschaue in der ampel die frau
strack-zimmermann die etwas äußert herr
linder
deutlich andere akzente setzt dann sehe
ich ein hofreiter und ich sehe ein haar
berg der auch deutlich andere akzente
setzt ich höre herrn roth und nehme dann
zur kenntnis was der bundeskanzler sagt
das alles geht kaum zusammen und selbst
vizekanzler und kanzler haben keine
einheitliche strategie ich sehe
allerdings auch dass es bei friedrich
merz und der diskussion um schwere
waffen
scheinbar weniger um die ukraine und den
frieden geht als um die politische
profilierung und auch machtpolitischen
gewinn ich finde das alles wirklich
furchtbar findet auch eigentlich
inakzeptabel dass es jetzt erst ein
antrag der union gibt der wird dann
wieder zurückgezogen die ampel macht
wegen des antrags der union eigenen
antrag der wird jetzt behandelt in jedem
fall werden wir in dieser woche dieses
thema im deutschen bundestag debattieren
und vermutlich auch prominente passieren
ich finde das wirklich
wichtig und auch richtig ich stelle sie
mir noch eine bemerkung zu dem thema
waffenlieferungen weil auch hier bin ich
der auffassung dass eine sehr sehr
unehrliche debatte geführt wird in
deutschland immer so getan als wenn
diverse länder schwere waffen in die
ukraine geliefert hätte es gibt aber
nicht ein panzer der nato der ukraine
und auch kaum schwere waffen es gibt
wenn überhaupt die ersten entscheidungen
in den niederlanden aber ansonsten gibt
es das bisher in dieser form nicht und
ich sage ganz klar dieser wettlauf
schneller höher weiter der ist an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich falsch denn man muss
ganz sachlich sagen dass mit den
jetzigen debatten niemanden geholfen
wird und ich kann nur für mich sagen ich
hoffe dass es ein waffenstillstand gibt
bevor der erste nato panzer in der
ukraine ist kann nur hoffen dass das
genau nicht geschieht denn die gefahr
einer eskalation des krieges bis hin zu
einem weltkrieg die ist ihnen nicht von
der hand zu weisen und deswegen wünsche
ich mir viel mehr zurückhaltung nicht
nur in der politik auch von den medien
war es hilft uns allen nicht wenn dieser
wettlauf fortgesetzt wird schwerere
waffen mehr waffen schneller liefern
dass es meines erachtens falsch
ja vielleicht hilft uns das nicht aber
dem krieg in der ukraine eventuell und
den menschen die dort täglich um ihr
leben kämpfen wie soll dieser konflikt
zu ende geführt werden wie kann man
putin stoppen frieden schaffen ohne
waffen lieber herr barth stadt ist die
frage wirklich gestattet wie stellen sie
sich das vor das weiß kein anderer hier
im parlament außer vielleicht der
linksfraktion jedenfalls die anderen
fraktionen debattieren jetzt über den
antrag unter an die ampel fraktionen
einbringen eben auch schwere waffen an
die ukraine zu liefern drei monate im
dritten monat pardon nach dem
kriegsbeginn hat sich der krieg in
richtung osten zu einem stellungskrieg
verwandelt und schwere waffen sind
offensichtlich notwendig um dort die
russen zu stoppen in der tat wie dann
eines tages eine lösung aussieht das
weiß heute keiner darum geht es aber im
moment heute ihr nicht sondern um die
frage wie kann deutschland hilfen und
eingreifen und da musste die ampel sich
erstmal rütteln bevor sie diesen weg
gegangen ist damit doch dann die fragen
sondervermögen 100 milliarden
da braucht man eigentlich die beihilfe
mit hilfe der größten
oppositionsfraktion der cdu/csu weil man
eine zweidrittelmehrheit bauten das
grundgesetz zu ändern das ist zumindest
der wunsch der ampel fraktion und der
cdu csu dafür muss noch viel geredet
werden mittwoch also die erste lesung am
donnerstag die abstimmung über den
antrag schwere waffen in die ukraine zu
schicken es ist viel los im politischen
berlin und es wird die nächsten tage
sicherlich nicht weniger werden und
damit zurück in unser studio nach boden
vielen dank gerd joachim von voll war
für diese berliner einsichten und
natürlich wie sie das von phoenix kennen
werden wir ihnen dann die sitzungen des
deutschen bundestages auch live zeigen
ja die unterstützung für die ukraine die
läuft ja auf see